fait que je me concentre un peu
donc il faut que je chante donc
répandent et en chantant
alors quel est pour vous le en folie le
comble de la misère alors on va faire
l'interview chanter imiter ou aimeriez
vous vivre si vous n'habitez pas paris
donc elle frontale et joue le plus
d'indulgence j'en ai que des erreurs de
jeunesse des avc ça bravo
montbard quelles qualités préférez-vous
chez l'homme c'est pas une qualité ils
soient drôles et qu'ils soient gentils
il est détruite alors justement ils ont
évolué même si vous n'étiez sa ligne au
sein et des treuils croatie reconnu
auriez vous aimé si vous n'étiez pas
vienne folie rêve à écouter j'aurais
voulu être humoriste 1
mais les flics interview jacques demy
l'année dernière question qu'elle est à
présent de votre esprit mal à
complètement
franchement c'est bien les grands
moments de cette émission mais c'est
vrai ça a toujours été un jeu pour moi
limitation de deauville hotline ont
depuis vu mais à prix doux depuis alors
depuis oui sur les bons choix il faut
que j'aie lac ou de l'anase sur les
dinos achille tonic